[Music]
you know what's fascinating is that you
obviously have a lot of fans and and
fans for different roles but you have
fans for your character alien and spring
breakers that are incredibly intense
about a character of alien I love them
and they take it my people those are my
favorite fan does your favorite alien
fan the alien fans that's how you know
like this ones and these fans are
hardcore
to the point that they're getting
tattoos of alien on your body that's
that's like a segment like within the
intense alien fans the tattoo fans it's
a yeah it's an order like this it's a
Morin it's the most intense yeah so
there's the there's the fans of the
movie
then there's the fans that dressed up
like alien in the Spring Breakers for
Halloween right a lot of them they were
really great and but the ones that say
and then there's the ones that get the
tattoo yeah and that of obviously that's
a commitment for life to the character
of ALS so we should be very careful
about what we say because that tattoo is
not going away
yeah actually we have one we have one
there there is one right there
not so crazy yeah
[Applause]
what is the body bars in a thigh or an
Armour what I think that's a leg
no that's the forehead it's an earlobe
gets it here though it's tiny well
here's the thing it's like you got to
have you have mixed feelings when a fan
gets a tattoo you have mixed feelings
because the one part you're like I'm so
honored but then there's a part of you
that's like yeah well also because it's
a tattoo you can't be like you can't
ever say it's bad okay I'm never going
away so like just be like okay yeah
thanks well when someone it's the same
thing like that guy that that musician
Drake had a fan that had Drake tattooed
on her forehead mm-hmm it's like crazy
ya know what I mean yeah so when people
come up to me like I've had a couple
people come up to me on the street me
like well you just write your name on my
arm or like draw a picture on the arm
and I'll get it tattooed Oh
you don't want no I don't want to be
responsible it's too much responsibility
yes also when someone shows you a tattoo
there's only one reaction excellent
that's been dressed exactly
we had Andy and I were on a tour a
couple years ago we were touring around
and there was someone that worked on the
road crew and he wouldn't mind me
telling the story but he came up to me
one day and it's like he had a bunch of
tattoos and he said Conan I've been
waiting all my life and I finally got
the tattoo I've always wanted a tattoo
and I'm it's so much pressure and then
he full he rolls up his arm and right
here he had left a big space for it r2d2
holding a Corona
and that's like who first of all you had
that idea like 15 years ago as a kid he
was like one day
how does Archer he doesn't even have
hanging yes he does he has a little
thing that comes up it has a little
Corona holder apparently I'm gonna get
it tattoo you should get that on your
forehead man won't affect your career at
all now in the new movie homefront
you're playing you're playing a drug
dealer and there's a theme here because
this is what you did in Spring Breakers
have you thought how you would be if you
had to be a real drug would you be a
good drug dealer
would you be good at it I play I think
this is my third probably I probably
played a few other drug dealers at some
point but I played one in Pineapple
Express one in Spring Breakers and that
one here but no I would not be a good
drug dealer I you know if you put aside
like this the high the the all the
glamorous murders all the addiction all
that you know all that all the you know
unlawful activity it's just like a
business right and like I hate business
hate that part while I keep track of my
inventory or like
like hey I gotta sell more drugs
Oh like I don't and he's also like it
he's a meth manufacturer the guy in the
movie and like I was horrible at getting
chemistry like I'm like I'm the sidekick
on Breaking Bad like yeah I know how to
do it yeah but also you'd be I just see
you like I gotta keep receipts where do
I report to taxes what don't I this is a
drag